nice to meet you you look like you're
gonna give me trouble so I'll make sure
yours is the only name I memorized this
week don't have to come to my prom later
the leftovers are my groceries anyways I
tell that you're drunk but we don't
technically have a policy against it
so I'm pretending not to notice so I
don't have to document it well I'm doing
room inspections I'm judging you by the
stuff you have tagged the liar I'm only
asking for your ID so that you know I'm
documenting this
I pretty much have your information
memorized by now please just take these
condoms now so we don't have to have
that awkward conversation later
I know who you are and I've told you so
many times to keep your ID with you I'm
just gonna let you sit out there for a
little while I have three papers due
tomorrow do you really think I want to
write this report as well really Jonah
Greeley door side of the argument but I
have to act impartial so we just keep
spouting nonsense love the dorm trick in
your room it really doesn't bother me
but if you mess with my door tags then
it's on
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half